Las economías costeras dependen de la pesca y el turismo.
Si la gente piensa que no podrá trabajar,
no aceptarán localmente lo que que necesitas
para que el área tenga éxito.
Hay que imponer las áreas marinas protegidas.
Significa que el gobierno debe estar profundamente involucrado en el plan.
El apoyo simbólico no lo logrará.
Y por último, la conservación requiere dinero.
Mucho.
Los gobiernos de naciones costeras pueden querer proteger sus aguas,
pero a menudo tienen una deuda muy alta
y no puede darse el lujo de priorizar la conservación.
Si dependemos solo de filantropía para financiar la protección marina,
podríamos lograr aquí una pequeña área marina protegida,
otra pequeña allí.
Pero necesitamos más áreas marinas protegidas más rápido,
para tener un impacto duradero.
¿Cómo se ve exactamente la conservación de los océanos?
¿Cómo obtenemos el dinero, apoyo del gobierno y una planificación cuidadosa
que tenga en cuenta las economías locales
y los complejos ecosistemas?
Queremos compartirte una idea audaz
del The Nature Conservancy.
Busca abordar todas estas cosas a la vez.
Se han dado cuenta de que la deuda de las islas y las naciones costeras
es lo que les permitirá alcanzar sus objetivos de conservación.
La idea de TNC es reestructurar esta deuda
para generar los fondos y la voluntad política
para proteger arrecifes, manglares y pesquerías.
Por ejemplo, si refinancias tu casa.
para aprovechar una mejor tasa de interés,
tal vez usen los ahorros para aislar su ático.
Así lo hacen los Bonos Azules para la conservación en todos los países costeros.
Refinancian la deuda,
luego usa los ahorros para crear áreas marinas protegidas.
Claro, la reestructuración de la deuda soberana es más complicada,
pero es la idea básica.
Si los inversores ponen USD 40 millones ahora,
pueden desbloquear hasta 1600 millones para la conservación del océano.
Y así es como se hace el trabajo.
Paso uno: negociar el trato.
La nación costera se compromete a proteger al menos el 30 % de sus áreas oceánicas.
A cambio, The Nature Conservancy atrae inversionistas, financiadores públicos
y organizaciones internacionales de desarrollo
para reestructurar una parte de la deuda de la nación,
lo que lleva a tasas de interés más bajas y períodos de reembolso más largos.
Paso dos: crea un plan marino.
Simultáneamente, The Nature Conservancy trabaja con científicos marinos,
líderes gubernamentales y actores locales
para crear un plan de conservación detallado
que integre las necesidades del océano con las necesidades de la gente.
Paso tres: activar para la longevidad.
TNC crea un fondo fiduciario de conservación independiente.
Se incluye el ahorro de la reestructuración
para apoyar nuevas áreas marinas protegidas.
El fideicomiso responsabiliza al gobierno por sus compromisos,
asegurando que los Bonos Azules financien esfuerzos reales de protección.
¿Podría funcionar este plan?
Ya lo hace.
En 2016 TNC ayudó con un plan nacional de conservación en las Seychelles.
TNC reestructuró USD 22 millones de la deuda del gobierno.
Y a cambio, el gobierno acordó proteger el 30 % de sus áreas marinas.
Hoy las Seychelles van en buen camino
de proteger 400 000 km2 de océano.
Esa es un área casi del tamaño de Alemania.
Las Seychelles están protegiendo sus arrecifes de coral,
reponiendo sus pesquerías,
mejorando su resistencia al cambio climático.
Al mismo tiempo, están fortaleciendo su economía.
Este éxito está haciendo que otros gobiernos tomen nota.
Muchos quieren ser parte.
Hay una oportunidad para escalar esto drásticamente.
Y rápido.
TNC ha identificado 20 naciones más en las que tal plan debería ser posible.
Pero necesitan capital semilla.
Y poner en marcha equipos locales para desarrollar planes,
trabajar con todas las partes interesadas y estructurar tratos.
Si reciben el apoyo que necesitan en los próximos 5 años,
podrían proteger 4 millones de km2 de océano.
Eso es 10 Alemanias.
Esto aumentaría la cantidad de áreas protegidas
en todos los océanos del mundo
en un increíble 15 %.
Permitiría que las vastas pistas de arrecifes de coral del mundo se repongan
y dar refugio a innumerables especies.
Esto sería realmente increíble.
Y es realmente solo el comienzo.
Porque no hay 20 países en el mundo
donde este tipo de conversión de deuda funcionaría.
Hay casi 100.
Con este enfoque, todos ganan.
Gobiernos, ciudadanos locales, financiadores,
y, lo más importante, nuestros océanos.
Así que de hecho, todos ganamos.
Ah, los océanos de la Tierra.
[El Proyecto Audaz]